uh maybe you guys can help me here i'm
confused bill maher got the vaccine then
he got covered he just got it came out
yesterday and said that
and so he's not doing his [ __ ] like the
first time in his career he's
missed a show yeah that's what he was
saying i don't okay so apparently if you
get the vaccine you can still get covet
obviously bill maher is it that you're
less likely to
to give it to someone if you have
received the vaccine no
that's not the case it's that your body
can quickly fight off the infection
without causing you to go through the
disease you're less likely to get
symptoms
and asymptomatic spread is possible or
is not possible i don't remember
uh i don't know i'm not a doctor no i
don't know
that's something we should probably know
having gone through a pandemic well it's
just that there's been conflicting
reports
so that's why i'm always just like you
know for a lot of things if someone told
me like what do i do if i
like break my arm i'd be like okay well
i'm not a doctor
said it if someone if someone asks for
like first aid advice okay i've done
hostile environment training i can give
you some general first aid advice
but this stuff is is contentious tribal
i just say talk to a doctor to figure
out what makes sense and what happened
with bill maher
he got he got sick but he's asymptomatic
because he's been vaccinated
so you can still get it but you can't
like you're not gonna die from it so i
guess the people that got vaccinated are
they still think there's a chance they
might get it and that people
might asymptomatically spread it so
they're putting the mask on just to be
safe i mean honestly i don't know i
think people just don't know and they're
scared
i think you're right i think this whole
time
most people did not know what was
happening
they don't well i think the big divide
between
you know in the culture war is what i
refer to as the uninitiated and the
initiated the people who pay attention
to politics who watch the videos and the
people who just
passively hear things so if you're if
you're following a lot of this news
you've got a much more you're probably a
lot more relaxed about everything
because you've seen the reports you've
seen the numbers in texas and florida
going down you've seen voucher's
statements and you're probably like okay
i think we're going to be all right
and if you don't pay attention all you
see is masks everywhere and warning
signs and street closures and cities
shut down
so you're really scared about it i think
a good example is like kyle rittenhouse
where if you follow you know we we had
we we've had richie mcginnis here
numerous times and i don't know if
you're familiar he's the journalist who
was actually there and actually rendered
aid to the men
so he tells us what happens and we get a
clear picture and we're like oh that's
really interesting
but then i hear from people who don't
pay attention to the news kyle
rittenhouse took a gun across state
lines and did all these things like none
of which is true
so they're angry and they have this
distorted view of things
a lot of my friends uh like i have a
really good friend of mine who's like i
want to come and visit but you know i'm
really worried about traveling
and i'm just like whatever makes sense
for you and like once i get my vaccine
you know i'll i'll think if i could i'll
figure out if i can do it or not and i'm
like
it's by all means in terms of the show
i'll give you a better example
i've re there was um i'll just i'll just
mention the people
um there's a very famous leftist hassan
[ __ ] he's got one of the biggest twitch
shows he's got a big youtube channel
um and he's one of the most prominent i
think he's a democratic socialist i
don't want to label people
but uh i tweeted it's very difficult for
us to get leftists on this show
because they just refuse to do it
they're scared of being cancelled i
don't know
and then i had two personalities one of
which was hassan and they tweeted
quote tweeted me saying i'll come on
your show and i was like
fantastic yes dude i mean hassan on the
show would be awesome i'd be so excited
for that
he's he's a popular leftist we have
great conversation we probably disagree
a lot of things
and uh i said we'll pay for your travel
let me know what dates are good for you
and then he messaged me and said oh bro
coven i can't travel
now now to be fair this was last year
when you know it was like
i think around august or whatever people
were a lot more worried
tons of basically every single leftist
we reached out to said because of covet
i won't travel
last night i was looking but real quick
every single conservative personality
was like where and when
no questions no issues and uh i would
say
a decent amount of the conservatives who
come got their vaccine
a decent amount didn't and they say i'll
take responsibility for myself
and for most of the i would say
we followed all the guidelines it wasn't
that crazy out here to follow the
guidelines we have like hand sanitizer
we were sure how many people come in
not hard to do and conservatives didn't
seem to have an issue with it
but people on the left mortified i was
looking um at
michelle it's it's an abbey in france
have you ever heard this place it's like
on an island it was this duchy of like
normandy and
it's this beautiful giant island
monastery and i was like oh i want to go
there
i can just go there for a weekend and
check it out and then i i realize like
oh yeah covid
i just what a hassle like you gotta i
don't even know what france's
regulations are
standing in line being around them am i
massed am i vaccinated
what like i just gave it all up i can't
i feel like i can't even travel
because you can't we went to aruba a
couple weeks ago
with my family but we had to jump
through hoops to do it but i was like
you know what i'm done
you know we've had a terrible year with
loss in our family
you know you talk about us in covid but
the kids
my children 12 years old 10 years old
wearing those masks in school
when there's hardly any risk for them to
get it
going outside for a 10-minute mask break
not being able to socialize with their
friends having
plastic around their desks it is
soul crushing i think what people need
to realize about their kids too
is that i think you know we're all
a bit older so for us we've experienced
so much our personalities have formed
we've become mature adults
to someone who's 10 years old a day is a
lot longer
because they're forming these
experiences they're developing into the
people they'll become in the future
so when you take a year which is a tenth
of a ten-year-old's life ten percent of
their life and you turn it into this
thing
that's gonna affect them for the rest of
their life i know it has my ten-year-old
i feel it i know it he
every day you know mom when is it over
this is the worst year of my life
yes yes i mean and it manifests itself
in different ways you know
we had a we had this little fish this
betta fish
for like eight months and we loved it
and the betta fish unfortunately died
but my theodore the ten-year-old has
been so upset
over that fish and i know that obviously
as as a young
kid going through something like that
and as a loss
but i know it's magnified by all of this
that we're going through you know the
deaths in our family yes
but the fact that he can't be a normal
kid i mean he's going to remember this
for the rest of his life it's just a
it's a year that they have lost and the
teacher thing i mean
you know i haven't talked about this a
lot but you know my 10 year old had
an issue with the with the online
learning he
he just was not able to really
process the information through the ipad
and it was getting to the point where
he wasn't learning anything and so we
put him
in catholic school because they they
were
going to school the teachers were there
they were in person
and we made that decision because he
just was having such a hard time doing
this remote learning and i talked to so
many parents
that are worried about their kids that
went through a year of this that really
didn't learn
much of anything yeah and it's so
disappointing
i mean you know i love our teachers it
really is a noble profession right
but the ones that you know didn't get
vaccinated or continue to not go into
schools well why are you
why are you a teacher then have you have
you been concerned at all with critical
race theory in the schools
of course of course have you seen
anything like that
you know i haven't uh i i worry um
you know listen i grew up i grew up in
canada
and you know i my best friend was
indian and but i never you know looked
at that i never looked at her
by the color of her skin i would go over
to her house and i would i would love to
learn about her traditions and her
family
uh and you know now nowadays it would be
like well you have to you have to
acknowledge the color of her skin
and i am of the belief that you know
what i i want to be colorblind i don't
want to
you know judge somebody my by my color
or their color
you know and i know that that's taboo to
say that these days
isn't that the progressive position from
the era of civil rights that's what they
wanted
and now the kids are going to school i
bring this up just because you mentioned
the ipad learning stuff and a lot of
parents were finally seeing their kids
were learning this crazy racist
and not just racist stuff critical
theory in general encompasses all
aspects of identity
and then decided to send their kids to
private schools to catholic schools
so i was curious of that no but i will
say that that has been one
thing that we've been able to see online
you know i
you know watching these online courses
you you see these teachers how they
really are
you know we're lucky because i i believe
that in our school district they
they're in it for the right reasons and
but man the stuff that you are seeing
some of the parents that are
you know calling out these teachers i
mean unbelievable so maybe
that's a silver i mean that's the wrong
word silver lining but maybe
maybe that is something that you know
we're now paying attention to because of
this
i think it's you know i a lot of people
don't like to say something like this
but
you know when god closes the door he
opens a window or something like that
there's always
you know you look on the brighter side
things like that people don't want to
say that because the pandemic's been so
brutal
to a lot of people but it's it's that
it's never just black and white
if there's something that came out of
this that could be at least in some way
considered to be beneficial it's that
parents got a warning about
you know what was going on teachers were
freaking out you know early on in the
pandemic they were
there's like a viral video where one
teacher was saying we have to make sure
the parents don't hear what they're
telling their kids
how do we deal with this these zoom
meetings are so bad because the parents
are now figuring out
we're teaching their kids this crazy
stuff that's creepy
the parents should get a pamphlet being
like here's what we teach your kids
and the parents should be able to go to
their kids and say what did you learn
today apparently
they're being told don't tell your
parents i told you this creepy
indoctrination
yeah the one thing that i will say that
i will remember this past year
is i've been at home you know i've been
i
since for a year now i've been doing
weather in a spare bedroom in my house
they made a green screen i never thought
it was possible you know like
a few years ago people say oh why don't
you just build a green screen in your
house and you don't have to go in and do
the weather
anymore and i thought oh that's never
going to happen well here we are
um the one thing that i will say is just
being at home and seeing my kids every
day that's something that's been very
special to me you know
i'll love this year for that very reason
just to be connected to them
working from home is incredible i
started in 20 2012
and never looked back i can't ever we we
tried the office thing a little bit but
what the commute i mean an hour a day
two hours a day
come on what a waste of hours in my
opinion i
i love it i do i mean i miss going in
and me
you know seeing my friends and my
co-workers but i'll be honest if i could
do this for the rest of my career i
probably would
and you but you would go out and talk to
people on the street too and everything
yeah of course
i do miss that yeah i do yeah i hope
that we get back to that
regarding kids that are having trouble
learning like you were talking about um
i think was your son earlier do you know
if are the schools being like lenient
about this are they passing kids through
without getting good grades that's a
good question um
i think some are i really think this has
been a lost year for a lot of children i
really think that some kids
should you know go through
the same grade again i mean i don't
think that that will happen but
i saw you know my child go through this
just
you know trying to focus on the screen
and not being you know
my theodore is somebody that needs to be
interactive with people and have someone
in front of him sort of you know
showing him um so i i really think that
i had to do the right thing
and get him back into school because
that's the way he
learns the best and it's a private
catholic school so you're probably
getting
i'm not trying to disparage public
schools but i imagine it's better
in some ways yeah i mean my other son is
still in the public school but he had no
problem sort of doing that transition at
home so i have one in the pa
you know the public school which i i
love i was brought up in the public
school system
um but for my other son who needed to
have that
uh interaction and i will say the
catholic schools did it better
do you do you think that this whole zoom
thing has been harder on
boys because i know they have such a
greater like level of energy
i think that there might be something to
that but you know i'm not a psychologist
but i'm sure that you know they could
probably tell you i'm sure they'll be
doing studies
after this they're uh they're saying no
more snow days anymore
that's as a person who does the weather
boo yeah what's that all about well uh
snow day right you're in school and it
snows and then you're sitting there
staying at the news
and then they're like there's well so so
when i was a kid
we didn't use the internet you know back
in my day we had the tv
and it would be snowing and it would be
a couple inches we'd have the tv on
and they'd be announcing school closures
and we'd be like come on
and then they'd say you know mark twain
elementary yes
and then we went outside make snowballs
and throw them now they're like
and the schools that will be doing
remote learning today in the storm will
be
can i tell you a secret uh that happened
with my kids and i was like
you're off sick today yeah yes
i love it that'd be cool if they gave
kids like one day a month that they just
didn't have to go in or something that's
a great idea
but they they do i mean there there's
holidays
yeah they're like the kids choice a
kid's choice there's something because
it's a great idea
i think we need more of that actually
maybe more than one
maybe like five and non non-consecutive
days where a kid can choose to take a uh
you know a permitted absence yeah yeah
but they start to do the homework or
whatever
the so getting on to this tangent we
talked about the fact that
i took my family to aruba and it was
great
but i will tell you uh just going
through the hoops
of the covid tests you know
getting the kova test beforehand then
going to the airport and having to check
your luggage and going up to the
the ticket counter and them checking
your documentation to
show that you got the kova test and then
you know if you don't have it
online my husband had it online and they
were like no we need to see the
paperwork
and thank goodness he did the paperwork
because they didn't want to do the
online thing
so you're in line for two hours you know
socially distancing to get onto the
the flight we went through like
several security checkpoints to show
them our documentation to get on the
plane
you finally get on the plane then you
arrive in aruba
and the same thing you've got to show
the people at the airport that you have
your documentation
and then they give you passes so that
when you get to the hotel
you have to show them the past that you
got at the airport to
prove that you had your covid test oh it
was
i mean listen it was lovely that we were
there we were able to go
to a beautiful place for a few days with
our family
um but the hoops that you had to go
through and i think a lot of it is
political theater
i'm i'm lucky i'm grateful i get to
travel around the world before
all these lockdowns and everything you
know in the past 10 years i've been to
dozens upon dozens of countries that a
lot of people aren't going to be able to
do anymore
i mean it's it's not just about getting
the tests some of these places require
you to spend like two weeks
yeah right in a hotel and like two grand
up front
people are gonna be able to travel my i
haven't seen my mom
in over a year and a half because she
lives in canada still
and and it's not good there she was in
lockdown uh very recently
because she lives in ontario and the
numbers were going up so they
you know they basically said you were
housebound for a month you know we do
we do the zoom time and stuff with her
but i mean
i worry about you know her not getting
out you know she's almost 80 years old
and she's
a fit 80 year old and the other thing
about canada
is that they have been terrible with the
vaccines terrible
my mom just got her first dose and she's
almost 80 years old wow what was the
problem
the canadian government you don't say
yeah they don't seem to be doing all
that well no
i mean a lot of people i think canada
and their health care system needs to be
more of a story here in the u.s to be
honest with you
i have ms i was diagnosed with multiple
sclerosis
16 years ago and a story that i tell
people
is that i was actually almost diagnosed
in canada
but they told me i had to go back to the
u.s to get an mri because i would be on
a waiting list for
over a year to get an mri to be
diagnosed yeah
one of my friends brought her dad back
to the u.s to have cancer treatment
because they were going to put them on a
list too it was going to be something
like four months when you have cancer
you don't have four months canada's
great if you're healthy and you don't
have like a chronic illness
do they have private health care too
does it do they mix it up i i you know
i i would guess that you could probably
if you're
wealthy you could do that or you just
come to the us
if you're dirt poorer or homeless i'm
sure you'll take a wait list over
nothing
i guess however in the united states
emergency rooms have to admit you
but there there's still some
complications i i don't want to get too
personal but there's some stories
you know i know with people in my life
where they they were stuck in canada
wishing they could get to the united
states for proper
healthcare treatment because in canada
they don't have the same level of
technology
right and that is correct part of the
reason the mri machines is because they
didn't have
them wow yeah yikes
i mean listen i i grew up there i have
fond memories of
of being in canada but as somebody who
has a chronic illness
uh and to have we really have the best
health care in the world
when did you when did you leave canada
uh i was in my
mid-20s what made you want to leave or
what made you sad you know
uh career choices uh i felt like
you know i truly believe i'm one of
those people living the american dream
because i wanted to be a broadcaster and
i felt in canada they kind of put a cap
on what i could do well
you know you're doing the job that you
should be doing right now and you really
can't go much further than that
whereas i felt like you know i applied
for a job in new york city and got in my
car and i didn't have much money and
packed a suitcase and i moved to new
york
but um man having to be surrounded by
all of those
those evil white supremacists at fox
news must be just so difficult
i'm kidding i know you are no i've been
there for the viewers though
i've been there 18 years and truly it's
like
they're like my family i you know i've
made some very
good friends there and uh and i feel
really lucky to work there but you're in
new york
yeah i've i've heard from many people
that a lot of the people who work at fox
news in new york are actually liberals
well you know to to be quite honest with
you no one
asks who the person voted for like when
i went for my
job interview no one asked me who i
voted for or you know
uh whether i'd identify as a republican
or you know a democrat that was never
asked and
you know i don't know who actually you
know what i
the people there are some people that i
work with that i know are not republican
but
i it doesn't matter yeah as it should
that's that's the way it should be but i
was talking to somebody uh i've been in
an in and out of the fox building i've
been on jesse's
jesse waters show quite a bit and uh
people were they were telling me like
it's new york what do you think you
think the people in new york city are
all much a conservative so of course
they're like liberals who work at fox
news
but these are the people that might be
liberal but working alongside
conservatives don't view them as
you know nazis or whatever stupid lie
the other media outlets are pushing
but i guess the name of the game today
in media is
hyper partisan tribalism and it's the
weirdest thing that
you know growing up fox news was the bad
network you know bill o'reilly and
sun goes up sun goes down you can't
explain that kind of stuff and now
for whatever reason maybe it's just
political or maybe something really
happened
fox news is the outlet actually bringing
on opposition voices actually having
challenging you know conversations
and the other outlets are just trump
sucks the right are bad people
fox news evil right well those ratings
it's
not rating anymore though the trump
sucks stuff
right i mean what what are they gonna do
next they gotta
they gotta think of another plan well
they tried going after tucker
you know brian stelter over at cnn was
like tucker is the new trump and
no one cared i see what they were trying
to do you know they
they had cnn had this really long streak
of trump sucks
and it did really well for them in
ratings without trump they need to find
a new
villain they tried tucker didn't really
work because
tucker is not the president thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you